the mandalorian mr mcgorriam's wonder
riporium doug
brown and his delorean
sporian for that burn nice
we're gonna watch from new rock stars
today the mandalorian two
by two breakdown star wars easter eggs
and spiders
explain and if you guys haven't seen our
reaction to the mandalorian season two
episode two it's now up on youtube
and where's my where's my baby yoda
because i don't know you're neglecting
the child
right now he could have fallen into the
completely wrong hands and now i have to
stall
while you do this hey reject nation
oh you're back right
i found him
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of the
mandalorian season 2 episode 2
the passenger a big group of an episode
both in terms of its job
and we all kept shouting at yoda's binge
eating there are actually a lot of
overlooked details this episode
including a new
threat to mando and baby that i think
we're all missing
and the real reason i think baby oda
might be eating those eggs let's find
all the easter eggs this episode
to have his a baby or yoda
the first thing i was wondering is how
did you get away with that
hi i'm shirt why not new
rockstarsmerch.com okay so every morning
here we go we opened back on tatooine
and you might have noticed a wider
aspect ratio this season it's a more
cinematic angle showing off the western
inspired landscape imagery and i
appreciate how the classic
lens flare trope is compounded to
account for both of tattooing sons
the bandits who scare me are led by a
mukdo
the nekto cartel overtook tatooine's
crime operation
after jabba's syndicate fell the one who
holds baby yoda at ninth point
is the same race as the jerk who snapped
at ray on jakku in the force awakens
that's what it was it's like familiar
dude
but when they're applied to stunt work
like this they make each blow and fall
feel more authentic and the fact that a
nick doe led this trap makes me
wonder whether this was an isolated
incident or organized plan thought out
you guys noticed they're targeting it's
definitely organized
get the child they're waiting for him
following the child
or we're told where to find them and the
editing includes an insert
the final guide looking at boba fett's
helmet but not
taking it that could mean boba who did
spot them last episode could have
alerted this gang or it's possible that
they were stopped by
pelimoto no no
no
[Music]
to alderaan peyton reid directed this
episode he directed the marvel ant-man
movie so this could be uh to add to his
own work but if you watched closely in
episode five last season
both dr mandible and this wrong woman
were visible
no way
get some shirts get some shoes
dude pretty soon they just need new
rockstars pants you can get a whole
outfit
waterproof and weatherproof these bad
boys are breathable
letting the air out without letting
water in
so things stay nice and fresh unlike
some
big old clunky boots sure spurs sounds
cool but they must be really impractical
these are like the ridge wallets of
shoes
they fit like a sock they only weigh 175
grams they're also made with this space
agency
um you know just make it up in your mind
and then you're right super easy
clean if you're going on hikes or
running errands or they're imaginary
units of measurement
that people use outside of america will
keep you comfortable protected and
looking great
you talked over eric's brilliant joke
crushing it so i'm just gonna spray
[Music]
my shoe all wet but my feet are dry
these are wearing messies thanks bestie
you saved
and if you missed the black friday sale
no worries you can still use my
code new rockstars to get 25 off your
besties
i'm gonna do a breakdown video of all
the new rockstars sponsorships
they're connected what idiots array
is the same hand lando calrissian used
to win the game of sobaka and
rebels not so fast it appears i have an
idiot
you could also hear me playing this same
hand in solo
[Music]
is great it's a kind of nod to galaxy's
edge where a restaurant roasts meals
that's exactly what i was thinking about
yeah i like it
for crying out loud apparently rodians
like their meat cooked well done
no i'd like to think kylie could be
making fun of greedo the rhodium whom
han solo david sleep they stop within
the same cantina booth pelicans just
sitting in
where han solo cooked that rhodian well
done the frog woman is disappointed
also performing the movements and this
character wants
that's cool she said her husband has
settled on the estuary moon
of trask in the system of the gas giant
collide
ah we saw this gas giant in the trailer
as the battery racer amy sedaris
[Music]
because when he presses his adorable
face against that tank
you can see the eggs suddenly moving
closer to
him also notice that every time baby
yoda slurps an egg
he does it in one goal
there's no chewing there so is betty
yoda
eating these ingesting and digesting or
is he like devouring them for
safekeeping the way i get ourselves
these cups
what how does this digestion work yeah
one of these up and that line could live
on as a lover of the music on the show i
got a shout out jordan's new baby yoga
theme
is that the baby yoda theme that's
officially what it's canonically called
it's just hard not to see this chow down
as something pure and altruistic
that's where we were getting confused
with two new republic x-wings piloted by
captain carson tiva played by paul sugg
young lee and the returning trapper wolf
dave maloney cameo and returning from
episode six last season that's why he
recognizes the razor crest from the
incident at bottom five
commando tries to weigh them off may the
force be with you
now of course manual doesn't really know
what the horse is he doesn't really know
the jedi religion but presumably this is
just a new republic salutation now that
he has memorized to get out of
situations
just like this one that's a much more
efficient way to say that than what i
said
i was trying to get it
designed some really cool details to
emphasize how frigid this ice planet is
notice the
cross-covered edges of lando's helmet
and armor that decreasing increases the
episode goes on
and the weight is gauntlet boom sticks
frozen to his dashboard frog
funko pop of frozen man episode bringing
back the voice of comedic actor richard
valuati
my husband has risked his life to carve
out existence for us
and as mando helps the frog woman scoop
her eggs out of the hot spring video
wanders over to some different eggs this
scene imagery very much inspired by the
moment kane
and an alien came across the facehugger
eggs as well as the big ol egg patch
laid by the xenomorph queen that
ripley finds in aliens now these spiders
at first glance do evoke the krikna of
rebels but
they're actually an original trilogy
callback the knobby
white spiders that the qriknow were
based on the older spider being an
original design
by ralph mccrory for dagobah and empire
strikes back
that was in 1993 and then when they get
back to the cockpit the next play now
reads maldon
crease and ignition offline guys now the
crease is the name of the ice planet
where amanda found the withdrawal in the
very first scene
he's going to come back maybe a
different more rugged part of it or it's
just a new destination popping up on the
screen and mando could be returning that
plane in the future we did see in the
trailer that horizon stands
yes returning late in the season so we
could find out why he was on that plane
to begin with then the mana spider is
blasted away by the two x-wing pilots
who committed man over his good deeds
toward the new republic
security records also show that you put
your own life in harm's way to try to
protect that of lieutenant david from
the new republic correctional corps
david was the officer played by matt
lanter who was anakin in clone wars and
the last couple details the
markings of x-wing some painted ties for
presumably each one he shot down i count
seven at least which
more than five would make him an ace
also the orange over there translates to
rescue meaning these pilots might be
part of a new republic search and rescue
corps kind of like their
coast guard now again check out
rockstars.com
i said space cops space caps
space what bay bay space watch
yeah you have eric knocked it out of the
park again
so many things are not notice killing
the game
that i will retain 10 of the necessary
information
already forgot the names of the spiders
that you said
they're just they're not the other
spiders from the clubhouse
i mean there's a couple of things that i
thought were presented here that
honestly bring up some great points
especially at the beginning with nikto
i mean you do hear them say where is the
child and bringing up the
fact that nikto took over tatooine's
crime
operation after jabba's syndicate fell
you tie that in
also with boba fett returning here
and i i feel like what we're gonna start
seeing down the road is more of kind of
like that gangster
crime snicket vibe on tattooing when we
finally do get boba fett back in here
like for real screen presence time
getting more of like the backstory and
how he really links into this particular
season i don't think that theory is far
off because this is a few years after
return of the jedi a few years after
jabba the hutt has died
and then if you have that being explored
here and like that makes sense why they
were looking specifically for them
it was such a a quick moment and i think
we're all kind of used to them hunting
down the child that maybe we didn't read
too far
into it but that was very much an
organized operation they were doing at
the beginning they were clearly
anticipating and tracking and then you
do
see boba fett's helmet so yeah i think a
lot of this
could be tied in i don't know why
specifically the look at boba fett's
helmet i don't know if that's implying
that boba fett gave the information or
not the thing about pelimoto though
no i hope that's not true no i love her
so much
she's such a great character and i feel
she's one of the few people in this
galaxy mando can trust it would be
heartbreaking
and there are a couple of little moments
there
yeah yeah you can start to hone in and
be like
i'm suspicious now maybe your behavior
and especially the way she sets up the
whole mission with the frog lady and
then she's like i only just met her like
five minutes ago
yeah before you know but they didn't
bring up the frog lady here did they
did they talk about what her race was no
one seems to know what the frog ladies
race is yeah nobody seems to know that
although it was cool to know that that
she
and uh i forget the name of the ant
creature now but that they were both
in the cantina the last time dr matt
mammovle
yeah dr man oh that was close
dr mandible there you go mandible with a
hannibal
hannibal get a can of
yep okay having the the actor coming
back here
oh she she is the andy circus of this
show
the unsung hero of all the somewhat
shorter stature creatures
this is like that moment if you watch
our reaction or
if you haven't seen it yet when baby
yoda is going to
the eggs we were going back and forth
because you were thinking he was going
to eat the eggs and i was like what i i
kind of feel like
the force is is pulling him towards the
connection
there's this wonder happening and then
he ate it like oh no what are you doing
so that detail though that eric pointed
out of when he puts his hand there and
the eggs do gravitate towards baby yoda
i think that is an indicator i mean i
don't know how much the whole thing with
the swallowing versus chewing really
factors in i don't know a baby yoda's
digestion it's like i imagine the guy
died and digest though he seems to eat a
lot in pretty much anything
it seems and they seem squishy and
blobular enough that he could probably
just suck him down like a like a boba
that moment played out so specifically
though and then the rest of the episode
was kind of a funny thing of he keeps
trying to eat the eggs he keeps wanting
to eat the eggs
yeah so i would like that if as the
season progresses or maybe in the next
episode you do find out that there is
some type of actual connection
and that it's not just some funny thing
that he wanted to eat the eggs or maybe
it's both maybe it's like he doesn't
really quite understand or something
thus he's eating them because they look
yummy but also maybe there is yeah a
connection
between either baby yoda and these
particular
you know species eggs that he's able to
explore or maybe it's just something
that he's able to
do with any life you know at that stage
or something but they're leaving
tattooing right now
where boba fett is where nicto is
they're doing this delivery mission
what's gonna bring
mando back to tatooine though why why
would he have to go back there
i wonder if it'll be kind of a bookend
season you start off at tattooing and
then you end at tatooine
and i think that would be a cool way of
then you get boba fett back then
this is called chapters yes instead of
episodes so i think it would be a kind
of a cool bookend if you did it that way
honestly whenever beaufort comes back
i'll be fine but he's on tattooing so
you know
yeah having some kind of bookend quality
or some kind of crisp
way because yeah it's like he's appeared
ostensibly
there's the one time at the end of the
last episode that's obviously him but
a lot of people think that he also
picked up fennec shan so like
to have that happen part way through
season one and then have a gap and then
have that appearance at the beginning of
season two think another gap and then
yeah come tie that back around at the
end with the return to tattooing yeah it
could be very cool and that
seems like a point in the season like
yeah in the later half or the last
couple episodes where then you would
have a lot of things coming full circle
coming back together
being revealed yeah you know especially
in the serial in the overarching sense
if i remember the first season
well enough you know that seems like a
lot of those bigger overarching answers
will come
then the maldo-crease planet returning
back to there what a great catch
my god what a great catch yeah really
tying those easter eggs
i don't know i would never have picked
up on that i do love that it is
for sure dave filoni's character
actually returning and
i love those are my favorite kind of
easter eggs where the tie-ins are such
deep cuts
but they are part of a continuous plot
line like you have to pay attention
he's referencing incidences from chapter
six of season one
and uh dave filoni is back from as that
character and
i feel like he would only really
remember dave filoni if you're one of
the fans who's like
oh let's say you know what i mean yeah
and so actually having a solid storyline
here that's such as part of the writing
of the show that i really do appreciate
a lot
yeah and the stuff that makes it feel
lived in and like you know everybody in
this galaxy
really is existing even when they're not
on screen yeah
you know i think it's really great that
with the spider characters of how they
scrap that design
for empire strikes back now it gets a
chance to really have a moment to shine
fully realized like when we we saw it
you know it did
kind of bring me back especially to the
the
the parts of hoth of luke skywalker then
to find out that that originally was for
empire
i think is a really great tie-in that is
very impressive
there are a lot of these videos man and
that's the kind of service that feels
a little bit more qualitative than just
like oh remember that it's like oh
here's something that they always wanted
to do before but they couldn't
yeah we're going to bring that we can do
it give it kind of its own little
stage to be a centerpiece that's really
cool yeah
ah well baby yoda is going to be pushing
out some weird hybrid
of yoda creatures meets frogs and uh
with a little little peppering of
spiders on top
this is a reference to aliens so this is
going to be like the alien three
alien with the dog and the xenomorph
meshed
and uh that's what the fans want it's
just gonna come and start killing people
whatever baby you don't you know poops
out
yeah it's just going to be an immediate
strong horror movie yeah oh god
cut to black all right guys well
mandalorian season two episode two keep
a lookout for our next reaction
subscribe to new rockstars if you
haven't done so already who do you think
the frog lady is what do you think baby
yoda wanted with the eggs hit the like
button yep
i don't remember everything that's
supposed to be said
lance door john why don't you take this
one away
lance door if there's anybody in our in
our little reject
galaxy that would be the mandalorian for
us it's definitely you i mean you're out
there
you're fighting the into the galaxy's
fires
so to speak or in this galaxy literal
fire you've got a young you got a child
to look after who you do with all your
love
and with all of your might because you
know i mean you're a pretty sexy and
formidable chap
so uh yeah man i would be honored to
just be cradled
in your powerful arm as we zip around
the galaxy in some kind of you know
bright red fire truck style spaceship
i hope you're doing well and uh please
make these dreams come true for me
bring some of your canadian joy down
here that was very
good john thanks i'm not even gonna look
at you for approval this time i'm just
gonna
that's how good it is keep looking at
lance the lance dorian
[Music]
you